that's amazing that's awesome Yasuda
another oh my god that's a good special
effect that's not that that is very
impressive feat that thank you
yeah that's that's amazing Bob we I
think we early on with Castiel we talked
about doing something like that
production said it was too expensive it
was a little much I don't get it who did
you come as I came as Dean I'm great
costume how many animals did you kill to
uh given several thousand some of that
food who's counting
yeah anyway I have a question for Misha
no what why I know misfortune my
question my question was since your
character is largely based off of John
Constantine from Hellblazer um I was
wondering since NBC is coming out the
new show Constantine if your character
will change at all or if you would
consider your own spin-off show um I
think what I'm trying to do right now is
put together a little cease and desist
package for those guys because I really
feel like there's too much overlap
between Castiel's look and Constantine's
look now granted we did plagiarize the
look from the original Constantine so
it's it's circular but I think we have
like squatter's rights now it's art
I'm not an attorney but I think this is
sound logic yeah it's a common law now
in cases where complaints come in law
law or shits are wardrobe
did y'all hear about the new movie
constipation it hasn't come out yet
still got it still got
for ten years for ten years I've
listened to those jokes and they're
still not funny hahaha
sorry it was more to your question I
don't think I answered the whole thing
no you did mom what was the rest of it
uh spinoff
would you consider what there was this
question about spinoff I missed that
entirely um yeah yeah yeah great I mean
I sure it up I think that you know
there's talk of a spin-off a
supernatural spinoff personally I think
the strongest move would be would be to
make it a very Sam and Dean centric so
we just say just leave me behind to take
care of me hey hey with bar ah we wicked
we could finish out the last ten seasons
of Supernatural alone what would you
play my Butler that Italy what what's go
well done on the on the wings by the way
that's right thank you Joe